[Music]
and truth trickin news took the trick
cool submitted bite you guys deserve a
Hawaii camión thank you and you go back
again yes that was the cape psychiatrist
claimed this method of questioning will
help you determine if someone is not
lying to you lying tell me because I got
my tells when I would play the Mafia and
poker tell me yourself I'm not going to
tell you okay well it's body language
it's intuition every individual is
different but then when you pick up on
the tick because for one person it might
be they're just cold but then if you
understand after a couple hours and you
feel them out then you know that they're
not cold mmm they're just nervous about
lyin
so have you guys ever heard of Columbo
yeah yeah that's like my grandma show
yeah it's pretty legit i ramble she's a
like a detective tambien Oh Columbo I
don't know aggression
it's an old [ __ ] show this is for have a
revolver like a little keeps out there
it hasn't really hair no no tom he looks
like Michael like if you always wearing
a Members Only jacket no less Charles
Bronson oh oh yeah yeah yeah this is
Colin oh yeah yeah yeah
we no no yes I was a deal with gel and
then no to this guy they got to joke
this dude looks like he gets like
grandma's pussy's wet right oh yeah my
growl was so horny for Charles Bronson
oh yeah so psychiatrists are saying that
the best method to detect what do they
know if someone is lying or like to see
to try to get the truth out of someone
is to do the Columbo method and what you
do is you use casual questions to get
the other person that just talks openly
and you kind of like sprinkle into
questions like that whatever you're
trying to find out and you try to act
confused when you're speaking to this
person and when you're asking these
questions like Oh was it really like
or like you're just here you somebody's
lies get the truth out of them yes
that's to do okay okay yeah yes so then
they're saying so ask questions be
confused because then it will suggest
that you're incompetent like oh they
don't even know that I'm lying and then
killed them stupid just to be straight
with you know how you kill a person I
know from experience you skeet you
[ __ ] snap in first just want to kill
this girl
Oh like that huh yeah yeah anything like
always be friendly and welcoming and use
meaningless chatter to distract the
person and then give them like an
assault a false sense of security and
when they're relaxed enough you flip
into question and you're oh that was
Joe's method I've seen it happen live
you [ __ ] put down their guard you let
them come into your world and now you're
in the sunken place [ __ ] son can play
even had a mug with like a spoon and he
kept talking to them oh really you know
you know I'm cracking up I'm looking
when I watch that one you know how they
went to such a push like this what if
you're just really sweeping you it you
like bounce leap like that is so great I
wonder what was happening inside their
brain when they were fighting with the
other person that possessed them do you
think there was a battle inside the
brain like a boxing match
oh you're not gonna take it over nah and
then they fell that's how they make it
seen with the exorcism like when you get
possessed it's like the person is like
hell and then the other demons peers
over you that's nothing to look like
there's like an internal battle oh yes
right you bet not these are my eyeballs
[ __ ]
I agree listen to your voice is so busy
no I agree if I'm a voice back man this
is this is not cool makes me feel like
I'm too serious all the time here's a
heavy try seems a boys baritone that
[ __ ]
I left my Oh Frank Sinatra ha ha ha in
San Francisco not you guys looking at
that note though
slow how do you guys tell when someone's
lying some of lying I don't like it in a
realization I can't it's hard to tell to
be honest with you because like there's
people who love you all the time you
just kind of smell depends on the level
of lie too and some people they're so
good because they believe their own life
because they have selective memory it
would have like laïcité they're like
what way signs are you 32 you know like
um ah bro you're not even evening out of
it Oh trace I can't get a Kenda yeah
yeah like those kind of things are a
little I think it's easy to tell when
someone's lying if they sound stupid as
[ __ ] it's kind of like a kid that's like
no that wasn't me um oh I remember now
it was kind of me I think if you press
them hard enough you'll start like
admitting the fault but you know they're
[ __ ] lying
adults do that [ __ ] too no I didn't
crash the car no no I didn't do that
yeah this was a little different no this
is more about like getting someone to
admit to something versus somebody
finding out somebody's lying because
that's a completely different thing this
is getting something to emit kind of
truth tell the truth that's a better
completely different except yeah it's
true because I have heard of a certain
tells like that you can look out for
when people are lying like for example
of the fact that they tend to look to
the left a lot or they link whenever
they're saying a lie or things like that
I've seen things like that but this is
near to me like how to get the truth out
of someone you can use not Isaac oh the
thing about Casey Amelie okay see you do
better than my anymore taste me anymore
cuz kids lie all the time
yeah no I think I know I did I can tell
when Isaac's lying like this immediately
I look at how like your line I know you
are he's like sorry mommy I got it right
away your point mafia with them every
day the less you beat them the less they
lie I don't need them I know I'm just
telling you from my experience all for
real maybe that's why I like so much the
more you can let me eat my ass the more
I'm gonna lie because it's all about you
know what's gonna happen oh you're going
to get in trouble once you're in trouble
so you do whatever you can to not get in
trouble
because you don't get your ass beat
that's so thought oh [ __ ] that I'll
violate the trust between my parents I'm
not getting my ass beat don't even lie
to you - they'll be like okay this time
we're gonna do things differently
you tell me the truth and I'm not gonna
get mad - okay you know what happened I
gets told our calculator what you
[ __ ] stole the calculator you've got
to get mad and beat your ass you said
you weren't gonna beat my ass yeah get
off your chest coke a minute well now
now on I'm never gonna be like your you
don't keep their promises no yeah my dad
did that - yeah my dad personally I
don't think he cared about like white
lies you cared about like big loss you
know it means - like that was his I knew
I'm gonna break cause it's already been
when we started - Vinny oh ho ho another
nunchuck oh you have together because
white life don't bother me cuz it
doesn't hurt anybody white lines and I
mean and plus I like I used to always
get people the best doubt as long as
it's nothing to harm me you know so that
person is going to like I don't know the
same well where were you last night I
was clubbing all night but most likely
you weren't but it's like okay look you
have it let's go along with the story
what about that you know what cracks me
up is compulsive liars because they for
some reason they always have to [ __ ]
lie and it always comes out in a
bragging form yeah writing for yeah like
I remember we had this buddy that was
always [ __ ] lying for no [ __ ]
reason for the stupidest reasons right
and from going to my friend's house to
the restaurant he lied five times and me
and my friend just looking at each other
cracking up and every single one was
like oh you see that McDonald's over
there yep we gotta fight over there oh
you see that over there yup you know I
[ __ ] robbed that place and did and I'm
just like thank you like why why you
trying to prove like you're such a big
tough guy America's worldwide or some
[ __ ] yeah I know like you see that yeah
we gotta fight right there
three-on-one I [ __ ] beat them all and
in this we had deserved as a Aegean kid
it's not consuming but it was Nick right
and might he specifically didn't like me
and my favorite day all of us didn't
have a lot of
yeah I mean so if you tell us that you
have a lot of things like what's the
whole point when you tell it to a bunch
of poor people yeah I mean like eat the
kid didn't have a lot of money either so
like he would say [ __ ] like oh yeah you
know Mike if he had a scion tc at the
time right move on for us it was a brand
new car you know really get brand new
cars you know so when he got that [ __ ]
like oh that's dope because yeah imma
put a turbo when everybody I have in the
garage right now like the fuzz and well
alright cool and so Renee was even more
bold and ideas are cool I'm coming over
tomorrow
I know he does not I would turn it
though my god we've already changes that
man and so he did something else too
right so we asked them so we wanted to
like to kick ass somewhere at this
school this is just like multiple
puzzlers right so we want to go kick out
after school right and right oh yeah can
we go to your place like this you said
you know you have all the C's because he
told us like you got the Xbox not 360
but whatever the X Possible's at the
time and well cool score day once again
just full of life
alright cool we're Dakota house tomorrow
right if not you can right he goes by
you my sister's got to be dumb and we
actually had his number to assist it
right yeah you got new dog so no what
are you talking about like bro come on
man we just kept doing it over and over
and over but it was just weird because
we're all friends it's like I don't know
who you're trying to impress bro like
yeah we're all broke his [ __ ] [ __ ] we
don't got nothing do it like what's the
problem
you know pulse of liars and he would
also do this [ __ ] that which bothered me
had nothing to do with lying but this
[ __ ] would always take my hot cheetos
right and if I asked him for hot cheetos
he would give me oh he would do this to
that pissed me off he were like this
what even ask you like this cuz he
wanted hot shield huge do this [ __ ]
annoying dude could you imagine that
[ __ ] like you just shared like you're a
whole [ __ ] hot cheeto [ __ ]
treasure chest with them in the next day
night isn't it yeah he says this and
then you ask for hot cheetos no oh
that's not fair what are they okay when
you say now oh I just [ __ ] customer
good they wasn't that customer he
wouldn't give me food it's like we all
share our [ __ ] with you you're the one
who's ball and you let the new [ __ ]
car you can't give me a [ __ ] G no
[ __ ] dubturbo yeah with the turbo the
not a [ __ ] if a guy ate so
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] the up so curious
of like when you started to figure out
that he was lying all the time when he
returned the same day yeah like that
kind of [ __ ] I don't really question it
until it came off like he was putting us
down then I was kind of like oh it's
like me feel a little weird yeah he
would also do this [ __ ] to was piss me
off so all of us clearly like so when I
was a junior nano Sivaji
when I was when I was a junior in high
school is when I started doing better in
school right so at this point I had no
idea that if you studied you would get
crepe like it wasn't really a part of my
mind until I find it aside that okay
maybe I do want to go to college so I
would put a lot of effort into studying
and then I would finally get A's and
when I first got a 4.0 I was very
prodigal and then he comes up and he's
just like so you would really do like a
history test like we had the same
[ __ ] test with English adding study
lecture at all [ __ ] you know world
history that well they give it a [ __ ]
A+ on it you [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
so it kind of makes you feel bad for all
the effort that you're putting in so
that's like one of the catalysts that we
just started calling him out on
everything because at that point your
time he could feel bad about ourselves
yep Olivia Tuesdays I have no idea
actually I have no [ __ ] clue so I'm
still lying yeah but he actually it's
funny because we followed up on it
because he actually went to Davis and
the one of our friends actually Dorn
with him and he had a whole bunch of
friends with him at the time at the
first year of college and the second
year I asked what was going on with them
and he says that nobody's friends with
until they found out he was such a
compulsive liar about [ __ ] that they
eventually found out in college and when
you're in college you're a lot smarter
you picking the ball faster so he lost
all his friends there too hello my
mother Joe Malians
please like the video and for more
beautiful videos look up there
[Music]